[Music]
many many years ago before I became a
Christian I was an atheist and I was
involved
in many
occult
experiences and my father-in-law was uh
very active in the New Age
movement he brought out a magazine in
southern Africa called Inner
Space his uh wife was not my wife's
mother but stepmother his second wife
was uh deeply involved as well she would
uh act as a medium she used to teach a
program uh which was called the Course
in Miracles which was a channeled book
by uh
shookman who was a
psychologist and in this series in these
these lessons that you would perform you
could uh become like
Christ and that's why it's A Course in
Miracles and anything he could do you
could do as well because we are all
Christ in that philosophy your own God
yes she was also a medium in a sense and
she would have uh Liaisons and
meetings with Spirit entities that used
to appear to her so she would be in
session with like a
medium or like a
channel and uh
I was also through my father-in-law's
activity exposed to uh channel of
Africa these are individuals that
receive regular messages and through
circumstances I entered up in one of
their
temples where he was
operative and this Temple was this is
just background before we get to your
story about Spirit entities manifesting
was uh
designed like a temple of
Aquarius it had a
Podium like a preachers
Roston and there was the sign of
Aquarius was on there and then it had
microphones coming down from from the
ceiling and the guest list would include
ministers in public ACT public sphere
like uh ministers in government minister
of this and minister of that uh
religious figures and Sports World
really yes the sports world was very
well represented and of course the
medical world so they would have regular
sessions and receive
instructions and these Spirit entities
would manifest and speak to them but uh
there were also uh discussions about UFO
and individuals that would uh be
associated with
UFOs and in that area in the cape where
these activities were most prevalent
there was a particular mountain and this
mountain is uh very well known for UFO
activities and many of the new aged
people bought property on those
mountains so that they could be exposed
to these UFOs and and uh they believe
that uh people can be whisked
away and there were talks of there was
talk about a lady who lived in in that
time period her name was Elizabeth
claraa and she wrote books about how she
had been abducted by these aliens in
alien ships how she had been basically
married to one of them had children with
him and she was very famous and uh there
were many articles in in magazines and
newspapers and my father-in-law who was
also into journalism to a large extent
was very involved in discussions with
all of
activities and uh this was sort
of common discussion as if it was
something that that was normal although
of course it was paranormal
now as far as I was concerned I I spoke
to these channels
personally they actually showed me
letters of communication with high
government officials I'm talking Prime
Ministers and presidents of the world so
we're not talking Esa things and uh they
showed me letters and they obviously
thought I was initiated into that sphere
of thinking although I wasn't I actually
at that stage already come out but
before that uh discussion with these
individuals before I had actually become
a
Christian we were with my
father-in-law uh talking about all of
these issues and my wife and I went to a
restaurant which was opposite the ocean
so you had a you had a beautiful view of
the ocean from this restaurant
and as we sat there uh two craft
appeared over the
ocean and uh I saw these with my own
eyes and not only I my wife saw them and
everybody else in the restaurant the
restaurant had be big Windows facing
facing the ocean we ran to the window
and we watched these two object flying
and hovering over the ocean and they
they looked like UFOs round dis shaped
objects and they stayed there for a
couple of minutes sort of moving left
and right and up and down and then uh
two Mirage Jets from the military came
flying roaring across the
ocean and it was a
display that lasted for I I don't know
how long it exactly lasted a c probably
maybe 8 minutes 10 minutes somewhere
around there his Mirage would come and
and they would just rise and the Mirage
would unders shoot them they of course
have a a relatively large turning Circle
they would double back around and uh
these things were just playing the
forward going up but at incredible
speeds nothing that that uh our
technology could
equal and this display of Captain Mouse
carried on for a about well 8 to 10
minutes and then they just shut off with
a speed that is
unimaginable and disappeared and the The
Mirage circled for a while and then went
back to base and uh so I experienced
that with my own eyes and of course then
you start speculating what are these of
course the first thing that comes to
mind these are
extraterrestrials but the interesting
thing is that these
extraterrestrial so-called experiences
were often associated with this occult
World in other words associated with a
world where you speak to entities that
come and appear before you like in the
case of this uh stepmother of my
wife and uh these experiences continued
for a while and we were involved in this
and we even went to the mountain and
talk to people that were involved in
that and they had very regular sightings
it was a very famous spot for for these
sightings and occasionally there would
be uh something in the newspaper about
the sighting and this and of that but
very much like today just talk and
nothing else what is interesting is that
some of the reports that I heard was
that when these entities appeared and
you approached them there was almost
like a hypnotic activity yeah and very
often the entities when they appeared
had an emblem on them the emblem of a
serpent h on on their dress they were
dressed apparently you know like we
would imagine an alien space individual
would be dressed with his tight fitting
clothes it's like in Star Wars like that
so very much the the picture that you
would imagine that was presented but
very interesting to me is that when
these manifestations took place the
people involved would speak in
tongues so the experience is very
similar to uh religious experience in a
in a charismatic world so having that
kind of knowledge you put the two and
two together then you you realize that
perhaps or probably let me go that far
these are actually Spirit entities that
are manifesting themselves and what I'm
talking about happened to us 38 years
ago now when I became a
Christian and uh I'd moved from my work
in the city and I'd moved to a
Farm we just settled at this place in in
in a very rural area of southern
Africa and there was a young pastoral
couple that had come to visit
us and all of a sudden as we were
sitting and talking in the lounge these
absolutely brilliant lights started
flying around around our house right and
uh we ran to the window and we looked in
the these things were just shooting
across the sky like brilliant lights and
we watched these things for a while and
I said you know this is uh a demonic
activity although everybody else would
say this is a UFO activity of course and
the next
day uh the farmers reported that these
object had landed and where they had
landed there were burn
marks obviously from the kind of feed or
something that came
down and I realized that this was uh a
demonic manifestation I I believe it was
a demonic
manifestation and uh you know that Alice
Bailey says that the hierarchy the new
age hierarchy the
Masters and if you look at these Masters
they all resemble the pictures that we
have of
Jesus and uh
that they would manifest themselves by
the year
oh so uh 2025 is not too far away it's
not no and in in the writings of the
spirit of Prophecy we read that this
kind of activity will
increase and that there will be
manifestations of entities that uh say
that they they are relatives from the
past and if I if I look at our news
feeds that we have I I watch a couple of
news
channels uh just to keep up and a breast
with what's happening in the world so I
tried to have a balanced field of what
I'm looking at I try to have a a
conservative news feed and then a very
liberal one and somewhere something in
between mhm and on a daily basis I go
through three of them just to keep up to
date with what is the left saying what's
the right saying and what is the the
nowh in between saying and it's just
amazing how
many film stars and prominent people are
beginning to talk about these
manifestations I mean just today in one
of the news feeds this morning I was
looking at one of them and it stated
that this person's
wife had died but that uh these
manifestations were taking place in his
house and he was in constant
communication with her and that the the
radio would start playing or a CD would
start playing her favorite one and would
switch itself off and switch itself on
again now I know where that comes from
because in my own experience I had
manifestations like that in my own life
we had many many demonic manifestations
when we were in the world out there
dabbling in the occult and some of them
are not very
pleasant anybody knows my conversion
story then they will see that there were
some pretty nasty demonic activities
that were going on so these things are
not strange to me but trying to put them
into uh a prophetic picture where are we
heading oh what is the world moving
towards uh according to scripture there
will
be legislation that will be passed of a
religious nature enforcing certain
dogmas
Etc and in order for that to take place
people must believe in something
MH and it can be of a religious nature
it can be of a new age
nature uh these Spirit entities for
example will encourage the world to
change their
Lifestyles to become uh more
vegetarian and uh when I doubled in
those things some of those entities
would say and they speak in I recordings
I listened to recordings of medium
speaking and they speak in the voices of
the people people that they they are
representing MH like I listened to one
series uh of a
medium U manifesting the voice of cesil
John
rhods and uh the way in which he speaks
and where he is in the hierarchy and how
high up he is and how informed some of
you are and he'll speak about my dear
ones you know and
he they speak in such
a seductive fashion to to draw you in
and to tell you that you are on a higher
plane because you are experiencing these
manifestations and you are chosen
because you're supposed to be an
ambassador for this kind of thing and
they would say you know you must cut
down on your on your Animal product
consumption so that you can have a clear
mind to communicate with these entities
so you see a a a complete counterfeit
yeah of of the
truth there is there is truth and
elements of truth but based on a wrong
premise mhm and so I believe that these
manifestations will become more and more
and for every mindset there has to be
something so those that believe that you
are a product of the stars that you are
a grand creation or experiment by
exterrestrial beings that have come to
plant a seed on this Earth and when they
are ripe spiritually to go into the next
phase as they are talking about into the
hierarchy then they will manifest and
draw you into this higher position this
is of the new age
dream and uh so to answer your question
bluntly I believe that demonic
manifestations I believe that the craft
are illusionary like almost hypnotic
implants mhm that you see that they
probably not real they're probably not
really
powered uh vehicles of any kind but are
actually hypnotic
plants there is a spiritualism coming
that we're told about in the great
controversy that I think um is is not
the world is not prepared for yet if I
may I want to present uh this is what
started this whole thing this uh this
this uh clip from Roger mono check this
out in reality Roger you were chosen by
high-powered demon spirits to be a part
of their human special privileged group
he says we are the Elite
we know the real truth about the master
and his angels and the priest told us
could I have a little bit more your time
I want to tell something very
fascinating he says the grain plain for
harvesting the multitudes of the earth
into his calls just before the close of
the great controversy between the forces
of Good and Evil and he said it's going
to be done in a unique manner this this
Grand plane is going to take people
people are going to eat the stuff
because it says Spirits demon spirits
will decare themselves to be inhabitants
of far distant planets in the galaxies
that are coming to warn the inhabitants
of planet Earth of the impending
destruction of the planet unless
something seriously proper is done to
avoid it it was a big thing that was
coming up one of the uh major deceptions
of the last days I've been going over
this topic week by week and the things
that you mentioned like the marriage uh
that the I just interviewed a I just
interviewed a guy who truly believes in
this stuff from
Professor down there in one of the it's
basically the iy league of the South and
he's absolutely sure that he has a child
with an alien on another craft and I'm
this has happened over and over and over
again when I talk to people about this
they say oh yeah I I have children I
have this I have that the hypnotic time
missing time people talk talk about you
said hypnotic and I I thought about the
missing time people say we know time
perhaps can't go missing but we we do
know that Visions can happen right and
you lose track of what's going on around
you burn marks I used to live in um uh
California when I left my property and
that my neighbors came over and they
said as I was leaving they said what do
you do with this this studio by
brendon's YouTube channel and we talk
about these strange things and as I got
into it he said well didn't you know a
couple years ago that there was a big
round glowing object that landed in your
field and left a giant burn mark
indention in the field I said I didn't
know this in my field before I bought
the property um and so and you mentioned
2025 we've we've gone over that with
Scott ritma he's done a lot of research
on that it was very interesting and the
activity that that you you just
mentioned I want to talk about that uh
but I have a clip that kind of goes over
that whatever the phenomenon is it's
capable of manipul ating human
perception mhm human consciousness right
it can make us see things that aren't
there I mean the best example of this
that I know uh is uh a story that jacqu
uh valet brought to me of a family in uh
France driving down the highway uh this
was like in the last 5 to 10 years and
uh they had a a glass topped car uh and
they look up and they see a UFO you know
basically paralleling them down the
highway the mother looks around and sees
that no other individuals nearby are
freaking out about this thing above them
the children in the back take out their
cell phones take a picture of it they
get home and they look at the pictures
on their camera and they don't see an
object they see a little star-shaped
thing about 30 so feet above it and I
have the picture even if it was an
object it was that was there others
weren't capable of seeing it so it was
manipulating
Vision so yes is the short answer and as
I study this I'm realizing that not only
can they manipulate it's basically like
a vision that they're giving these it's
like a vision yes yeah and uh the people
that come out of this these Visions are
very much like those that have attended
religious festivals where they go into a
Trans
State and very often they can't remember
the
details very often there
are even sexual connotations associated
with it and I would have brushed all of
this off if I hadn't had personal
experience and seen things with my own
eyes and had manifestations in my life
not with direct contact with beings like
with from the spacecraft or anything
like that but uh with the entities and
their manifestations and the problems
that they caused in our own
environment
so they they are definitely there and
they are preparing the mind for
something and you mention nuclear war
that they have to get rid of the that
they prompt Humanity to get rid of the
nuclear weapons can I play that real
quick that clip the full clip that is a
very interesting clip that there are two
things that they keep saying over and
over again number one you've got to get
rid of your nuclear weapon weapons
programs and secondly you've got to stop
polluting your planet with petroleum you
know that that you're you're polluting
your planet uh and contaminating it you
know and you're going to ruin the entire
climactic system of your planet at
that's stage the thing about nuclear war
was very prevalent but not not the one
on the climate impact of petroleum
products but for
example they would say that if Humanity
was to itself it would destroy itself
mhh so these beings actually will
manifest to prevent Humanity from
destroying itself but if Humanity
doesn't grow to the point where they can
transcend this this raw aspect of their
being then they might actually allow
Humanity to destroy
itself so that's why it's so important
that we grow into this age which they
called Aquarius ah yes that it was very
prevalent in the' 60s and' 70s that's
why they even made Sons the age of the
Aquarius that's right and so that's
that's interesting you should mention
that CU you you mentioned earlier that
you had a um a Channel of writings that
you you had seen that mentioned some of
this stuff this book called The Law of
one is it's also called the raw material
they call it ra a like the raw right
and uh what's interesting about this as
my I have a group of about 100 people in
Discord that um that help me research
this they're volunteers and they uh
they're they've done a fantastic job one
of them
um Aaron he found this is really
interesting from book one listen to to
this and tell me what you think about
it a channel
drve Yeah question can you tell me about
the origin of the 10 commands ments raw
the origin of these Commandments follows
the law of negative entities question
was this done by the Orion group Rah
this is correct question what was their
purpose in doing this Rah the purpose of
the Orion group as mentioned before is
conquest and enslavement question it
would be wholly unlikely an entity fully
aware of the knowledge of the law one to
ever say thou shalt not is this correct
raah this is correct so in other words
he's as they Channel this thing Rah as
he calls himself he's he's
saying there is a group in the Orion
area this isn't from Spirit of Prophecy
this is channeled writings from demonic
entities saying there's a group coming
from the the Orion area that created the
Ten
Commandments that is coming to enslave
Humanity right with
rules now this is very
interesting and uh he obviously also
refers to himself as
one now uh one with a capital letter can
be used for
God but Lucifer also likes to refer to
himself as one in fact the
one so in in the occult world he is
known as the
one and in the bahai world they call him
the wronged one H so that's
fascinating and he will manifest himself
in some religious movements like
Mormonism for
example they were the two
sons and Lucifer is actually the Elder
and his seat has has been us served
and he will regain his seat again so
this Cosmic war
against uh Christ by Lucifer the wronged
one I'm not saying that is in Mormonism
but this is in in the occult
world uh he is the real
lightbearer now we know that he's he's
war is against the law of
God and his law is do what thou wilt
is the whole of the law and we also know
from the spirit of
Prophecy that uh when Christ returns he
comes from the constellation of
Orion which is the constellation that is
visible both in the north and in the
Southern
Hemisphere and uh it's interesting
scientifically that uh where the Bible
says who can loosen the belt of a riot
that that is the constellation that is
moving apart where the B is actually
moving apart at a tremendous pace and
there's supposedly this nebula in
Orion which some believe is a black hole
but it cannot be a black hole because
out of a black hole nothing comes out
but there's a kind of celestial light
that is present in that
constellation which some believe is
actually the light from the city the
city of God so there are many
speculations with regard to Orion and
the cosmic battle between good and
evil so when this one says that uh um
enslavers will come from there it's
actually directly opposite to what the
opposite if it if it's God coming from
there and if you read the spirit of
Prophecy then it is States there that
Satan referred to the angels as deluded
slaves so as slavery to what slavery to
the
law so he believed that the law was uh
unrighteously forced upon moral beings
that should be able to make their own
moral
choices so if you read in the Book of
Genesis the three lies that Satan
presented to to Eve mhm uh one of them
was you will know good and
evil that means you don't need an
external standard to tell you what is
good and what is evil you don't need an
right and what is wrong you are a high
moral being you are a god yourself
therefore you are not subject to a moral
standard by anyone you are free from
that so any sub objection to a
law obviously in his mindset is
slavery whereas if you look at the law
of God uh the Bible calls it uh a law of
freedom because the only Freedom you can
ever have is if somebody actually keeps
that law we have no Freedom we are
enslaved because of law Breakers
uh a woman cannot go for a walk in a in
a park without facing the danger of
being either raped or murdered or
whatever she has no freedom to walk
because someone says he doesn't have to
keep the law Thou shalt not kill Thou
shalt not commit Thou shalt not do this
Thou shalt not lie so if you see those
laws as limiting your
freedom then have a pretty warped mind
because those are the only laws that can
guarantee your freedom MH
absolutely well this this whole thing
has stepped up a bit to another stage
just recently there's been a
podcasters government podcasters that
have uh come on and said you know what
we we're going to talk about this
because it's not being talked about
enough in our government we can't get
people in our government to do do things
about it because they are Christian they
said the Christians don't want to talk
about the UFOs because they believe it's
demonic and they're making decisions in
your government which we have a
separation of church and state
supposedly here in the US so they're
using that to try to get people on board
with not with talking about this more
this is a do Department of Defense
official saying stop looking at UFOs
because they're demonic correct he told
me he said Lou I want you to stop stop
doing this I said okay sir I I certainly
can but may ask why and he says well we
already know what it is he asked me
Point Blank have you read your Bible
lately and I said well sir I I I think I
know what it says what where are you
going with this and he said well then
you would know that these things are are
demonic and we should not be pursuing
them and one of the things that that has
happened is that the government
officials have come out and said they
are looking into a guy with the last
name bledo and so Chris bledo and his
son Ryan bledo were former Christians
that had had a significant experience
with these things more so than anyone
else understands and that's why the
government is so interested in them
because they say we see these things
floating around in our atmosphere but we
can't get to them they don't come to us
but they come to this family why I'm
going to show you a testimony from Chris
blood so here tell me what you think
about this and so I'm talking to the
heavens
to the sky just like this I'm done with
you I'll never speak of you again don't
come around me don't come in my house
I'm done with you and that's what I did
and I walked in and I went to bed I'm
I'm asleep 3:00 in the morning 3:00 on
the dot I heard this voice say arise in
a manly voice I mean it sounded like
thunder it was so loud and it woke me up
from a dead sleep till I jumped up out
of bed to a sitting position and I
looked around the room panicked I said I
heard that who's in here if it had been
my wife it wouldn't have startled me but
because it was a deep thunderous manly
voice that scared me to
death and I looked straight at my clock
had old desktop clock back then
everybody had alarm clock right I don't
use one so now we use a cell phone yeah
I looked and it said 3:00
a.m. and I could see movement in my room
and it looked like these shadowy figures
that we've been used to seeing they were
at the bed foot of my bed these shadowy
figures and what they did I don't know
they put me in some sort of trance like
Thing To Where I Stood I got out of bed
I was in just my underwear I Put on Full
jeans pants shirt shoes and I walk right
out the back door following them and the
minute I closed that
door I stood up and this blast of
wind it was so strong this wind it was A
Mighty Wind but it was localized it
wasn't the trees around me it wasn't the
forest it was a blast of air in a circle
in front of me and I fell all the way to
my back flat in the leaves and as I'm
falling I could see what looked like
a a 1500 lb bull a cow come out of that
hole ran right over top of me and I
could see through it I could see the
stars right up through it but I could
see this
bull and so I land on my back and I roll
to my stomach and when I roll and I'm
trying to get up right I'm going to run
I it happens within seconds I hit my
back I roll to my stomach I'm facing the
other way so I'm trying to get to my
knees and to my feet to run know where
this thing went and immediately
uh the cow wasn't there it was a
woman beautiful beyond
measure she was glowing this bluish
white
color and she had this um white dress on
that sparkled when it was flowing dress
just moved and it looked like an old
Roman dress it went all the way to her
feet and and sleeves out to her hands
here and a collar there's a painting of
her right
there that was done you painted this no
the man standing to me as a famous
artist from New York but she was
hovering barefooted just like that 3 fet
off the ground and she looks at
me I'm just in this biggest shock words
can't describe how the power I felt from
this wind and this bull run me over and
the fear that set in Flight of I had to
run you know I had this instant fear hit
me but now I'm looking at this woman so
that whole fear thing turned into oh my
God know what is this is this an angel
what am I looking
at she leans
over and she looks at me and she says
this is your burden she said first she
said you know why I'm
here and I knew why she was there
because I had struggled internally for 5
years these orbs comeing it talks
telepathically but she said this is your
burden you got to
bear and she said um several things
there's going to be trouble
coming and we're going to wake the
people up we're going to let you do it
we're going to use you we want to help
you introduce us to the world that's
what she
said so he said that what's going on is
this woman came to him and she told him
I want you to present us to the world
we're ready to come out to the world and
I want you to be the one to go and
present us basically making him a sort
of demonic Prophet for these things that
are coming out and not only did that
happen but she he said after the
experience occurred my dog ran into the
house and gashed his neck on some barb
wire and put blood all over the house he
said I ran over to the dog and grabbed
the dog and as I put my hand on the
wound to try to stop the dog cuz I am
miles and miles away from a veterinarian
he says I felt something happened in my
hands that I've never held before like
electricity going through my hands and I
took my hand away from the dog and the
dog was healed he said I have never
experienced anything like this and he
goes on and explains further that he
says after that happened the government
officials would come to me and talk to
me about these things that were coming
to them that they noticed were coming to
my my home and he said they took me to
Washington to Washington DC and as I was
there listening to these uh
professionals do their presentations one
of them at the dinner
table fell ill and fell over couldn't
couldn't breathe anymore or something he
said I I and they they they encouraged
me to stand up and go do something like
I'm going to do something he said the
table behind me I heard this Ruckus and
the band they were dancing just like
that whole crowd you know they know how
to party and they were having the best
time I'm sitting watching my children
have
fun and
uh I heard this
Ruckus next thing I know um Jim's wife
Debby grabs me said picks me up
basically and pulls me to this other
table and said you got to help this guy
and he was slumped over face
down I mean out Co completely uh turned
white and they were trying to revive him
couldn't get him
away and
uh they drugged me to the crowd and I
put my hands on his shoulders the very
instant I did he stood he sat up and
took a big breath and they looked at me
and said my God you you saved him it's
really really bizarre to see to to
listen to the hours and hours of podcast
that is happening to this family right
now cuz even the youngest youngest
daughter uh in the family says that
because of all this experience my father
has had is seen these orbs he says this
house that we live in has become a
haunted house things come up and they
push us at night they throw us around in
the kitchen and he says she says it's
bizarre what other types of experiences
are we talking about go ahead you can
talk I mean anything you can think of
really I've seen things we've seen
things like jump off of the table
without being touched like moving things
moving on their own seeing shadow
figures being touched um
anything like you would think it was a
haunted house growing up but that's you
know part of how we explain that this is
all spiritual in nature is because it
can really manifest in any way that it
wants to and so the phenomenon is not
limited to what people think of as
aliens or UFOs where we were obviously
seeing orbs every night as well we were
seeing things in the home that you would
think of as like ghostly maybe but it
was all the same
stuff well uh having had ult experiences
myself and having had occasions when I
was uh
strangled by demonic
forces I can relate to things being
pushed around thrown around I've had
things thrown around our
house Cutlery being thrown around
smashed all over my house I I've had
amazing experiences if somebody wants to
know more they can look at my
testimony but uh hator of course was an
Egyptian
goddess and and she was associated with
the cough with the cow she used to be
depicted as drinking directly from the
other of the
car and uh she has many manifestations
names isar for
example it's fascinating that she wore
white and blue which is the same color
that the manifestations of Mary in the
Roman Catholic church but also wear
white is the color of in innocence and
blue is the color of
obedience so she is the epitome of that
which is
acceptable and raah Amon ra is the son
God and we all know that that is a
manifestation of
Lucifer and uh the god
Amun Amun ra Amun was the deity of
Egypt he was the the sun god it's the
story of Seamus and nrod all of
those and there was a phase in
egyptology probably uh associated with
uh Moses and the
Exodus where there was a switch from
this monotheistic culture to a I mean
from this polytheistic culture to a
monotheistic culture
and
to it's an
am an am an is the sign of Life Amun is
the god so Amun is the one that gives
you life that's what to an Amon means
but he changed his name to
to so he became to Anan and his his wife
changed her name also to Tin so she
became
anart and this this was a a one deity
that gave life so there was this entire
switch in
egyptology and then uh there were a
number of uh people that died and they
they forced them back into the
polytheistic culture so he changed his
name back to tut an Amun is the one who
gives life and anen became anen Amun so
again Amon is the deity so what are we
talking about we're talking about a CED
religion which is Sun worship which is
Lucifer
worship and uh you have the horns of of
of the cow and in that you have the
solar Blaze so that solar Blaze is
represented as in the horns within the
womb that's the birth of the sun god so
it goes back to nrod to the time of
nimrod who was uh killed because of his
activities sentenced to death
probably and then was reborn through
semir
ramus and this is the The Cult of the
father mother
child uh religious system which also
find very much in Roman
Catholicism you have father mother
child and uh it's the old system of sun
worship and it has many manifestations
over the era so the names change whether
you when you go to Greek culture and
they change when you go to Roman culture
and they changed again when you go to
the Christian culture just give them
different names and different entities
but they're the same deities so they're
basically the worship of Lucifer um and
that's why when you had the um
experiences in before you could became
Christian and you got an exorcist to
come that they also dabble in that whole
world the whole time the and they would
have to say a
mass in in my own
situation uh the Catholic priest came to
say a mess in my house to R the house of
demonic activity and he would have to
say a mass which you need special
permission and the mass is of course
around this coost which traditionally is
placed in a monstrance which is the soap
of of the horns of the semicircle they
also use the moon as a Cresent so if you
go into a Catholic church or Cathedral
you will see Mary standing on the
Crescent Moon it's also the birth of the
sun god or because he's androgenic male
female it doesn't matter whether he
manifest as a male deity or as a female
deity what do you
think Aman ra is the hidden one means
any ideas well is is the hidden one is
the one
who who pretends to be the wronged
one but the time will come when he will
manifest himself and will receive
worship and the Bible says that because
it says he will manifest himself as an
angel of Light and he will impersonate
Christ now it's always fascinating to me
that the images that you find in the New
Age documents of the ascented Masters
that they look like Christ so if a being
should manifest a bright me being should
manifest in that form and repeat some of
the words and create healings because
healing is very great part of us now in
Many religious cultures uh in the world
today healing is you know part and
parcel of the religious
experience so he will he will put people
into bondage and make them sick and then
remove the bondage and they will appear
healed he's a counterfeiter and he's
pretty good at it and the reason why
probably like you mentioned he's hidden
is he has to manifest still that will
probably be coming and so this is like
the precursor Bossip play to that I I I
think it's really interesting to dive
into one of the things that Spirit of
Prophecy that we've SE not only in
spirit of Prophecy but we see hap has
happened in the Bible itself is that
um spirits will pretend to
be dead relatives dead relatives
necromancy for sure I have a clip I want
to show you I met
a I met a uh through doing this research
there was a guy that worked at Nasa in
Florida uh he works at the U blue origin
Space Center which is uh right where the
Kennedy Space Center is and um he's a
Christian and he's a he's a Baptist guy
he says I've been doing research in this
for 30 years not just personally but
because I'm a part of a group of people
called muon which stands for the mutual
UFO Network he says it's a group of
secular people mostly that uh look into
this stuff and try to write reports when
the police say this is way too strange
and we come in and try to validate
whether or not the person's crazy or if
there's some other legitimate reason of
something that's going on here he says
I've I've done thousands and thousands
of reports he said but one of the things
that stands out to me and something that
changed my understanding of spirit
spiritually is the understanding in
death and here's why something that
showed up that was unusual in the
research over our years that we've been
looking at this is not just myself but
other researchers I think Barbara bolic
was one of them Whitley streber we've
all come across cases where testimonial
of the
experience The person talks about
actually meeting dead relatives during
the experience when they're taking
aboard a craft and we've also come
across other researchers that have
talked about the same thing where
they've had to experiencers share the
testimony that they too have come across
um friends that have died or relatives
that have died during the experiences
and that doesn't make any sense at all
being that this is supposed to be about
aliens so he he he went on to say that
often times and to your point he says
often times this dead relative is used
as a control to make the abductee or the
person he says it doesn't always even
have to be on a ship he said the when
they have this experience this Vision or
whatever it is maybe it's it's uh in
real life he says it's not really for
sure what's going on but he says that um
this experience is used as a control to
make the person do something that's
against the Bible and usually it's
sexual and he says this is a major part
of the whole deception is to not only do
that that's that's one of most common
things in all the reports he's written
but the second most common thing is at
the very end of the experience they try
to make you believe that Christ is not
who he says he is this is he says over
and over and over he's like it was if
and if you believe in aliens it's like
these things came from miles and I mean
kilometers long light years away and
they just came to tell you that Christ
wasn't who he says he is says I don't
believe it well if you study the Bible
you know that the dead know nothing
and Satan is a master at convincing the
humanity that the dead know
everything and it's also fascinating
that the most despicable of men often
have the highest position in the
afterlife so when I was still in the ult
world you would listen to channeled
messages of individuals like Adolf
Hitler and he would be a higher plane on
the other side as even Jesus
Christ so that the most despicable of
people would be elevated to positions
above Christ is rather strange mhm and
uh he he will manifest as as deceased
relatives because that is the most
emotional bond that you can create
create now if you if you know the
scripture and you believe the
scripture then uh you will understand
that
uh it's it's a very powerful tool that
the de devil can use and even with our
Pioneers within our in the church within
the Seventh Day Adventist Church the
Pioneers often or sometimes rather let's
put it that way we're confronted by
their deceased relatives and their
deceased
wives and they would know what the state
of the Dead is and then they would they'
say you are a liar because I know that
you are a demon because dead know
nothing and then those entities which be
got on Danny and you going to read that
in in some of the stories of the
Pioneers W now I've had experience with
with the dead that were very personal
me and uh if I hadn't become a Christian
and if I didn't understand what the
Bible says there would be no way that
you could convince me that this was not
s i was uh the only
one who sat at the deathbed of my father
while he was dying so that called me
from in the hospital and said that I
should come and I was not a Christian
was an atheist but I was deep into
occultism and he was
dying and as as is the case in his
particular case his breathing just
became shallower and shallower and
shallower and then very
intermittent and then it stopped and he
was
dead and I sat there for a couple of
seconds watching him it's a very
emotional experience when you see one of
your parents die
right and he stopped breathing
completely and the next moment he sat
upright in
bed and he raised his arms and opened
his eyes and he went like this I nearly
freaked and then he fell back into his
bed and that was it he was
dead
now that image nothing can erase that
out of my mind it was he was so
overwhelming and of course my first
impression would be he saw my mother was
also dead he was being greeted
right and then I called the the nurses
and they came and the doctor came and
pronounced him dead and they covered his
sheet I went
home and I got into the car and I was
driving home and all of these thoughts
are going crazy in your mind
mind and the next moment the hair on the
back of my head went up and I
was absolutely convinced he was sitting
next to me in the car of course I
couldn't see
him I drove
home and I got home and I told my wife
what had happened of course it's a very
emotional moment your father's just died
these things and I went and sat in the
lounge and I just sat there and I
thought and I
and I said
okay if you're in the room with
me and manifest yourself show show me
that you are here and the next morning
the curtain went
oh it's a pretty freaky thing you have
no wind doors closed but the curtain
moves like that and uh I said okay all
right so you're all right that was it
but now come and tell me that's not real
yeah nightmare it's a nightmare right
and then when you discover the Bible and
you realize that that you were duped and
that it is a lie that it is there to
rather believe your senses than to
believe the word of God you have to you
have to deny your senses and accept the
word of God and if you then resist him
he will flee from you he will not he
will not be able to manifest
himself because his deception has been
exposed so how important is it that we
fortify ourselves with the word of God
and how many people in including
Christian denominations are driven by an
emotional experience yeah and that's it
can't go much deeper than an experience
with an
afterlife I the other day that some said
they had an experience like that and
there's no way that anyone will ever
convince them that it wasn't real yeah
because they saw their also death child
or something or the many near-death
experiences that you have where someone
sees an entity of light and you walk
towards it and you're told no you have
to go back now uh those
experiences I now know to be hypnotic
implants M they are they are hypnotic
almost like visions that are implanted
in your
mind and when I was involved in the New
Age
movement I used to practice um out of
body
experiences oobs seems is what they
called them and I recall standing next
to my bed looking at my
body now is that real or was that not
real and I could tell you what was
happening in the next room I could
actually go through a
wall and tell you what was happening in
the next room and uh my wife would not
believe it sometimes and go and verify
whether it was so or
not and sometimes you would have a panic
experience because you're trying to get
back into this body that is lying there
and you can't get back into it it's a
real state of panic and then you go oh W
and you jerk so that you fall out of bed
and you find yourself lying on the floor
now it's a it's a quite a dangerous
experience because there are certain
techniques in which you can use to
achieve that that state and one of them
is oxygen deprivation so you stop
breathing so you have to be quite fit to
do that some of the
fast and abstain from certain foods in
order to do
that and uh when you go through that
experience it is so real now was I
really outside of my body do I really
have a soul that is loose from my body
but the Bible says uh he became a living
Soul so the matter plus the breath the
metabolism makes you the living entity
you are the living entity the devil
tries to convince you that you are not
the living entity you are a shell the
living entity is really inside of you
and when that living entity comes out
it's Immortal so it was never really
created so you don't have a
Creator and if you don't have a creator
that means you are a God and if you are
a God you are a law unto yourself you
don't need an entity to impose something
upon you like a law so what is this
experience what is this that you are
seeing
yourself and then you get
this panic attack and you drive
yourself remember going like this on my
body and beating myself and
then falling off the bed and you're
bathed in sweat but you've had an
amazing experience right
yeah it's hypnosis it's not real it's a
it's a hypnotic implant
and if he does this over and over and
over and more and more people begin to
testify to these things then it's no
longer speculative it becomes a
reality and then he's got the world
where he wants them then he can spin any
story that he wants to and his favorite
story is to say is that Jesus is not
going says and probably the next one
will be that he's changed all the
Commandment stuff Chang the Commandments
and that Sunday is his day yeah that's
what's that will be the ultimate that's
what's happening next there's one thing
I want to end with this uh is is um have
a few Spirit of Prophecy quotes that I
think were very interesting I want think
uh have you comment on them because
these are some of the things that we
found as we were studying this um let
see if I can find them here just a
moment I have a a a document with a
bunch of them in here
so in the days of the Hebrews this is
from darkness before the dawn a
compilation in the days of the Hebrews
there was a class of people who claimed
as the spiritualists of today to hold
communion with the dead but the familiar
spirits as these visitants from other
worlds were called are declared by the
Bible to be spirits of devils it's a
very interesting quote to me because as
Solomon said I think there's nothing new
on the and so it looks to me to that
what she's saying here is that these
things back in the days of Hebrews they
claim to be inhabitants from other
worlds yes and so there is going to be
the same deception that's going to
happen again I think this is my my guess
that appears that Roger monno was right
and that there is going to be a big
deception coming of
spirituality um Spirit mediums in the
time of the Patriarchs in early Israel
King Saul went to S see the witch of
Endor mhm and uh they would speak to
these entities at their
idols and these Idols were like a like a
source of medium
Revelations oracles oracles yes and you
you have the similar manifestations
today you have in Roman Catholicism
statues that have manifestations that
have bleeding or tears or this that and
the other and people go into Euphoria
nothing has changed well even if you go
into the egyptology and all of those
either in the hieroglyphics they' of
thousands of years back there is signs
of manifestations of these type of
things and a great controversy uh we've
probably heard this before when they
have been led to believe that the dead
actually returned to communicate with
them Satan causes those who appear
causes those to appear whom went into
the grave unprepared they claimed to be
happy in heaven and even occupy exalted
positions there and thus the error is
widely taught that there's no difference
between the righteous and the wicked
that we all go to heaven all go to
heaven the pretended visitants from
other worlds of Spirits sometimes utter
cautions and warnings which prove to be
correct then as confidence is gained
they present doctrines that directly
undermine the faith in the scriptures so
she's going to they're going to attack
the scriptures next too and one of them
that she mentions that uh will claim
where it is claimed that he has an
exalted position in heaven is Thomas
Payne one of the viest occultists who
have ever lived was very influential
also within the early part of the
American
history you see it's very interesting if
we read that and then you read is it
blaska or Bailey who said of the
manifestation of the hierarchi it's
Bailey that says it but Bailey is the
the followup prophet of blaski so you
see so the occult prophets also says
that there will be um this manifestation
as long with what do we it's always been
there and it probably is the way it's
going to I expect it to accelerate
greatly within the next year I I do too
I think in fact as I was studying 2025
and
2027 we talked about quite a bit as
we've been going over some of these
writings for some reason but the last
quote uh from Darkness Leon I wanted to
present your uh ideas on is um fearful
sights of a supernatural character will
soon be revealed in the heavens in a
token and power of Miracle working
demons the spirits of devils will go
forth to the kings of the earth and to
the whole world so two two different
sections the leaders and to the rest of
the people to fasten them in the
deception and urge them to unite with
Satan in his last struggle against the
government of Heaven by these agencies
rulers and subjects will be alike
deceived persons will arise pretending
to be Christ himself and claiming the
title and worship which belongs to the
world's Redeemer and and she's quoting
here summarizing I guess um Revelation
16:13 which talks about the three the
spirits that go from the frogs and I
think or the frogs which are the spirits
that says it's the spirits and goes to
the whole world but I think what's
really interesting about that passage
that I had never read before or or maybe
I read it I didn't realize it but she
says the purpose of these Spirits not
she Revelation John says is the purpose
of these Spirits said that um it is to
Rally the armies of the Earth for war
physical War as if we can kill God and
so that's what's happening right now is
in the media we're seeing these things
they're trying to put weapons in space
or trying Star Wars wars United States
is creating this fifth arm of the
military called Star Wars yeah yeah
basically and it it it's called um star
war and then but it's not the only
country us is not the only space space
thank
you you know what's interesting is that
demonic Revelations and
Leadership of the
world has been very
common and uh even the presidents that I
have witnessed in my
life uh Ronald Reagan Bill Clinton they
all spoke about uh communion with Spirit
entities and they used
um zodiacal signs and uh and sign
readers to tell them when to do this
that or the
other
and yes people will say you're crazy but
I do believe that Satan is preparing a
physical war against the coming of
Christ as if he would be able to use
nuclear weapons or missiles to try and
prevent
it and uh even the Bible talks that
after the
Millennium he will raise up a great Army
and think that they can attack the city
and they will create weapons of war now
if you think that God with
one raising of his arm can destroy the
whole world with a flood MH then what
will they achieve by their activities it
is it is wishful thinking so is this for
for the benefit of the Demonic forces I
don't think so I think they are fully
aware that they do not have a chance
against
God but it is there to deceive you human
it to stay in Rebellion because they
could be convinced that they can
actually beat this entity so it will be
the whole plan is to take as much of
humanity with them in Rebellion as
possible fascinating thank you so much
this has been really really interesting
to go over this topic with you guys and
I appreciate you guys coming out and
doing this it's a pleasure was a real
people will say we're probably nuts you
know these are my experiences I cannot
deny them and uh
fortunately uh if you have accepted the
truth of the Bible and the truth as it
is in
Christ then you can be distanced from
these things you can observe it and you
can use every opportunity that you can
get to warn
Humanity but to be involved in it is
something something that I do not wish
any
pray Heavenly Father we know that
there's a great Cosmic conflict going on
behind the
scenes and demonic forces are not only
manifesting already but will be doing so
more and
more they will be taking on roles which
represent entities that are no longer in
existence and they will deceive many if
possible even the
elect so Lord I pray that you will Open
the Eyes of people take them to your
word make them realize the veracity of
your
word read it trust it believe it
implement it and be safeguarded against
these demonic
delusions and help everyone to realize
that there is only one way to
Salvation and that this Cosmic war is
really not against flesh and blood but
against the evil and the
principalities and the sin that is in
this world because the new world will be
without sin without fear and without
death and we look forward to that entity
which is real and not based on
Illusions thank you for your word we
embrace it and we thank you in jesus'
name amen amen
[Music]